the South Korean president gave a new
interview to Fox News's Bret Baier and
in that he said that the North Korean
leader will allow in inspectors would be
willing to verification is that true yes
and have any US or international
inspectors been inside North Korea so
we're working our way towards making
sure that this verification that we have
talked about since the beginning and
many have been skeptical Norah we've
talked about this verification for the
beginning we're we're not going to buy a
pig in a poke we're gonna get this right
we're going to deliver on this
commitment the Chairman Kim has made it
to the world and then there's going to
be a brighter future for the North
Korean people and there'll be a more
peaceful world that's what the president
talked about yesterday in his UN speech
and it will be a wonderful outcome if we
can get and do you do you envision at
this next summit with the North Korean
leader that there could be an
opportunity to sign a declaration to the
end of the Korean War it's hard to know
I don't want to prejudge precisely where
we'll end up but make no mistake about
it there is real progress being made and
we're going to continue to work at it
and until the point in time where as the
president says and we could be wrong it
may not happen but until such time as we
conclude we can't get this done we're
going to continue to drive to achieve
the progress continue the progress which
we've already made let's talk